-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show", everybody.
It's time to play "Password."
-"Password."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Well, our first team tonight,
he's the host
of "The Tonight Show."
And he's a four-time
NBA champion.
It's Jimmy Fallon
and Shaquille O'Neal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And their opponents -- She stars
in "This Is Us" on NBC.
And she's currently on tour
opening for Katy Perry.
Say hello to Mandy Moore
and Noah Cyrus.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh.
Now, the rules of the game
are very simple.
I will give each of you
a password.
Then you give a one-word --
that's one word only -- clue
to your partner
to guess that password.
The team with the most points
after four words wins,
and the first clue goes to...
Noah and Jimmy.
-Here we go.
-The password is "pinkie."
-Noah, why don't you
start us off?
-Finger. [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Finger.
-Only one word?
-Yes. Only one.
-Yeah.
-Can we steal the point?
[ Laughter ]
-You'll have a chance.
-I'm sure you know what finger.
-I already know the answer.
-Wait.
Can I do another clue now?
-No.
-Oh, okay.
-Shaq knows the answer already.
-How?
Did you look at my card?
-It's lickin' good --
finger-lickin' good.
-No, no, no, no.
One word.
-One word.
-Oh, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
-My bad.
-Oh.
-That doesn't count.
-I have another clue now.
-I think you can only
give one word, right?
-Right, one word.
-I'm going to guess middle?
-Nice, but no.
-No.
-Nice guess.
-I ruined it.
-No, no, it's okay.
-Jimmy, your turn.
You did not ruin it.
-You didn't ruin it.
-Okay.
-Jimmy's going to ruin it.
-So one clue is finger.
-It's one word back.
-Has to be pinkie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, whoa, whoa.
Shaq attack.
-It has to be pinkie.
-Oh, my gosh, that's nuts.
-Has to be pinkie, man,
if it's not -- Yeah, he's right.
-First to Shaq.
-All right, Mandy.
-And, Mandy.
-The password is "camel."
-Shaq, you are up first.
-Okay, buddy.
You can do this.
[ Laughter ]
-Hump.
-Sorry?
[ Laughter ]
-Hump. Hump.
The man said hump.
-You said hump?
-Hump.
H-U-M-P.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hump.
Humpty hump.
Wednesday?
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-That's a good guess.
-No. That's a good guess.
-That's legitimate.
-That is officially hump day.
-Okay.
You heard...
-Hump.
-...hump.
Toe.
[ Audience groans ]
-Oh, snap!
♪♪
-Camel toe?
-Yo!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Oh, ho-ho-ho.
It's a family show.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Is that legal?
-I don't know.
-That's legal.
-I don't know if that's legal.
-Oh, come on.
-That's legal, that's legal.
All right, Noah and Jimmy,
it's your --
-Well done.
-The password is "thriller."
-All right, Jimmy,
we'll start off with you.
-All right.
-You go. Don't say "hump."
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause --
-Say it again.
-Wait.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause --
-♪ 'Cause this is thriller ♪
[ Bell ringing ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
Oh!
-That was it?
-That's it, yeah.
-What did he say?
-'Cause --
'Cause --
That's all --
That's all we could clear, too.
-Yeah, that's it.
Yeah, don't say any more.
Okay.
-'Cause --
That's it.
-The final clue.
-[ Laughs ]
-That was amazing.
-Can't believe
you got that one, man.
-All right, Shaq.
-The password is "bark."
-It's 5-11.
-Okay.
-You can tie this up.
-You're going down.
-No, no, this is it right here.
I feel it.
-5-11?
Where did that come from?
-Odd math, this game.
-Yeah.
-You looked at it.
-I did.
-Okay. Okay.
-Ready?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh, they're in the zone.
-I --
-Yeah, what are --
-Okay.
-They got in the zone there.
-Yeah. AutoZone.
-Ruff.
-Dog.
-No.
All right.
-You just woofed.
[ Laughter ]
-Shaq.
-Wait, what?
-[ Growling ]
-Aah!
-Ruff.
-Okay. What is it?
Use your thinking cap.
No.
That's not it.
-Jimmy, hurry up.
I think I know.
-They have a bond.
They have a psychic bond.
-Bone?
-Ooh.
-Pimple?
-No.
-Oh.
-Hold on.
-[ Barking ]
-Wait a second.
Mandy's going to give a clue.
-Can I give a clue?
Can I give a clue?
-No, no, she answered.
-She answered already.
-I jumped the gun.
It doesn't count.
-And she was wildly off.
-Go ahead.
-Let her have one clue.
-Well, he went...
-Okay, ready?
Mandy, it's your turn.
-I didn't mean
to mess your suit up.
-Don't worry about it.
-Slobber.
-Ruff and tree.
-Put this on eBay.
-What?
-All right.
-Huh?
-What?
-Do I get a lifeline?
-No, you can't have a lifeline.
-No.
-Ruff?
-Ruff and tree?
-Yeah.
You've heard "ruff" is one clue.
And now the second word
she's giving you is "tree."
-Wood.
-What's that?
Wood?
-I said wood.
I don't know.
-Because wood is rough
and it comes from a tree.
All right.
-For the win -- bark!
-Bark.
-Yeah!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Laughs ]
My thanks to Mandy Moore,
Noah Cyrus,
Shaquille O'Neal, the champ!